se cree que entre 17 y 25 misiles las
cifras ni siquiera están claras porque
como dices han estado lanzando los todos
los todo el día y es posible que incluso
sigan haciéndolo ahora mismo lo que sí
está claro es que se trata de una cifra
récord para el régimen en norcoreano en
un solo día para que nos hagamos a la
idea hoy Corea del Norte probablemente
haya disparado más misiles que en todo
el año 2014 los misiles que ha disparado
hoy son misiles principalmente misiles
balísticos de corto alcance y misiles
tierra aire que ha disparado tanto al
mar de Japón hacia el este como hacia el
mar Amarillo hacia el oeste pero como
decimos Han sido tantos que tanto la
inteligencia militar surcoreana como la
japonesa han tenido problemas para
rastrearlos Y contabilizarlos por qué
tantos lanzamientos Pues el miércoles
Corea del Norte Ya advirtió de que
podría responder con contundencia a unas
maniobras aéreas a gran escala que se
están realizando estos días Corea del
Sur y Estados Unidos en la región estas
maniobras aéreas son las mayores de este
tipo en cinco años incluyen unos 200
aviones aproximadamente y especialmente
los cazas furtivos f-35 que son un
activo que Corea del Norte considera un
arma especialmente peligrosa para la
integridad de su territorio